SCP-682 Vs Dr. Bright. Could
this battle of the immortals
finally result in one of their lives
coming to an end? Let’s find out!
The plan was to get SCP-682 to ingest
Dr. Bright’s SCP-963 medallion,
erasing the beast’s consciousness and
replacing it with the good doctor’s.
From there, it would hopefully be a little
more cooperative with attempts to kill it.
But it didn’t quite work out like that. Dr.
Bright’s consciousness was at war with the
monster’s inside its body after eating the
medallion. On the outside, 682 grew giant
claws and tunneled out of the chamber, where
it ate the feet of one researcher, Dr. Samet.
Thankfully, Dr. Bright was able to escape
with his life and inhabit a new human body.
But fragments of his consciousness
were left in 682’s malicious brain.